if you're looking to buy a new tv in
2022 maybe it's time to save up just a
bit more to explore the wonders of qd
oled tvs
there aren't many in the market right
now but when it comes to first gen tech
you might want to throw caution into
twin and dive right in it's surprising
that this tv from samsung hit all the
right notes a small warning though the
moment this tv power's on you might get
sucked in and wonder yourself hours
later wondering where all that time went
after staring at this beauty of a
display hello everyone it's gerald and
today we'll be checking out the samsung
s95b qd oled tv
before we start geek culture covers
plenty of different topics from tech to
toys and the next video might be
different from this one do remember to
give us a like and sub at the end if you
found this review useful as it does help
the channel out a lot i've dedicated
2022 to checking out all the greatest
display tech that's coming out from all
the big boys today we are one of the
most anticipated tvs most folks have
been waiting for
with the global supply chain rebooting
getting the samsung s95b qd oled in your
market might be tricky to get hold of
but it's finally landed in my hands so
what's the verdict after using the
samsung s95b for some time
just like the alienware aw 3423dw
this is one of the best tvs money can
buy right now in terms of tech the main
issue here is the tvs ui which can be
tricky to navigate and this is
especially so if you might have less
tech savvy seniors in the home
as for everything else it's actually
pretty awesome with the tv you'll be
getting the rich black's front end and
oled the brightness of an led and even
richer visuals with no color filter
removing even more brightness one of the
things you want to do out of the box is
to ensure that your s95b qt oled tv is
updated
yes even tvs are subject to firmware
updates now and our set has been updated
to the latest 1302 firmware version
if you are not getting the latest update
pushed to your tv
do check out the link in the description
below for a manual update based on some
reports it will appear that individuals
have reported that samsung is not
pushing the update automatically and
you'll need to have to do it yourself
the changes here mainly affect the
filmmaker mode preset which has been
pushing brightness levels higher than it
should be
the best way to really test this out is
to put on content you like and play
around with these settings to see which
preset suits your taste to ensure it's
not washed out
after all it's your tv and getting the
color preset that suits your taste is
the most important
unlike other reviews where i do have it
in my study the massive samsung s95b is
sitting in my living room there's a big
window to the left of the tv and we'll
see how it fares under this lighting
condition
another thing to note is that we'll be
testing this tv right out of the box
without any additional toggles to really
see how well samsung has set up the
average user for success
specs wise this tv can hit 1400 nits
sustain on hdr on paper
in all honesty users won't care how
bright a white pixel can go because
that's just like staring into a
floodlight the real game changer here is
how good colors on the screen look
overall this tv shines bright and really
sets it apart from the competition
because the qd oled doesn't use a white
sub pixel like other oled tvs it can
achieve higher color brightness the
results the same level of consistency
that i had experienced with the
alienware monitor
it's definitely a screen that anyone
will stop and do a double take while
this might be a little controversial i
like how samsung's intelligent picture
mode brings out the best with whatever
content you have on screen on the other
hand if you're looking to gain final
calibration on the s95b be sure to turn
this feature off in order to access the
full suite of color profiles
overall i found that filmmaker mode is
rather muted for my liking on default
and will definitely benefit from some
tweaks under the settings menu
something that we have noticed when it
comes to content that is extremely dark
oled tvs tend to struggle a bit
depending on the room lighting situation
in our test to get a good sense of
declare on the tv we found the screen to
be glossy overall
however once content hits the screen
it's hard to observe any reflections
unless you are picking them out
contrast wise it's difficult to find any
fault with this tv at all the
consistency of the panel has held up
well and has everything we have come to
love about olets in general
when it comes to viewing the tv from
differing angles the tv looks great from
pretty much every corner of the room
however if you are using this tv during
the day under bright lighting conditions
the glare and reflections can become
apparent when it comes to design the
samsung s95 qd oled tv is pretty much
what every consumer should demand from a
top tier tv slim with small bezels
you'll be getting more screen on the
3840 by 2160 display
one of the more important aspects to
note here is that we have four hdmi 2.1
ports that point towards the right and
downwards as you are facing the tv and
that leads us nicely to the best part
about using this tv which is for gaming
equipped with alrm and vrr samsung knows
all the features that ps5 and xbox
series x console owners want to gun for
plus this tv even has free sync support
which means it could be very well be
used as a monitor but this is way too
big to be used on a desk
samsung has a dedicated gaming dashboard
that allows you to toggle the preferred
picture profile to fit the genre of the
game you are playing i suspect that most
folks will leave it at a single setting
but at least there are some options on
offer while you might be too big for a
test there's nothing stopping you from
plugging in a pc and enjoying the tv not
only in 16x9 but you have the 21x9 or
32x9 option this is specifically for
folks who love playing games for the
ultra wide experience however do note
that because the screen is not curved
you'll be missing out on some level of
immersion as well at this point i'll say
samsung put in this fixture because they
simply could you're able to double check
if you're hitting the numbers and
ensuring that neither tv or console is
lacking off
overall one should expect to achieve
120hz refresh rate easily with a
response time of 5 milliseconds one of
the more challenging aspects once you've
gotten this tv is figuring out all these
settings while samsung's tizen os and ui
feel snappy out of the box it does take
some time for you to figure out where
all these menus lead to for the most
part all your major streaming services
can be found here so there's little
worry that you might not be able to find
the app they are looking for when it
comes to audio it's amazing how such gen
tvs are able to eke out so much quality
in a small frame i would say the balance
is solid overall
and if you like there's even an
equalizer to give users some control and
achieve their preferred audio settings
to really get the best out of the tv
it's recommended to pair this along with
a samsung samba over here we have the
q-990b soundbar
which allows one to unlock samsung's q
symphony function and make full use of
all available speakers from both tv and
samba remote controls don't get much
praise but the one included with the tv
does away with all the buttons
it's so simple and sleek now and it
charges via solar or usbc we clearly see
the shift of the streaming walls here
with this remote and it looks like the
only missing streaming service here is
hbo so if you made it to the end of this
video i'm not quite sure if you needed
more convincing the only tricky thing
now is whether the samsung s95 qd oled
tv is even readily available in your
market hence if you are looking for a tv
right now and would like to dip your
feet into some future tech this tv is
the one for you
it's surprising that the first gen qd
oled tv displays have been able to
perform so well right out of the box
plus it's been a consistent and
excellent experience that i first
witnessed with the alienware monitor if
you have any further questions i'm happy
to answer them in the comment section
below until the next tv review this is
gerald signing off
[Music]
you